las familias de las víctimas aliviadas
por la justicia fueron cinco las
personas a las que Anderson lealdrich
les arrebató la vida el 19 de noviembre
de 2022 dejó también decenas de heridos
tras abrir fuego en el club un bar
nocturno lgbtiq más en Colorado Springs
ante el juez reconoció la autoría
mientras analizo los documentos veo que
tiene la intención de declararse
culpable de cinco cargos de asesinato en
el primer grado
46 cargos de intento de asesinato en
primer grado y dos delitos motivados por
prejuicios
es esto lo que desea hacer
si su señoría
addrich evitó lo que pudo haber sido un
juicio largo el atacante de 23 años fue
condenado a cinco cadenas perpetuas por
los delitos de asesinato e intento de
asesinato sin embargo los sobrevivientes
a la masacre esperaban que el atacante
también declarara por los cargos de odio
y delitos motivados por prejuicios pero
no sucedió el daño en la sociedad está
hecho Dijo uno de los sobrevivientes
no hay una resolución que sea positiva
porque a todos Todavía nos falta mucho
un compañero un hijo una hija un mejor
amigo alguien se ha ido eso nunca podrá
ser devuelto a través del sistema de
Justicia Colorado ya no tiene un
estatuto de pena de muerte pero si los
fiscales lo consideran necesario el
atacante también podría enfrentar la
sentencia capital en un tribunal Federal
la ONU advirtió que los derechos humanos
de la comunidad de sexo y género diverso
están siendo socavados deliberadamente
por leyes discriminatorias en algunos
estados de la Unión Americana antes de
Colorado la comunidad lgbtiq más había
sido blanco de otro mortífero ataque con
el tiroteo de la discoteca pauls en
Orlando que en 2016 dejó 49 muertos